>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Tomoko Steen: Welcome, everyone.
I'm Tomoko Steen here at the Library
of Congress Research Specialists.
And today's event is sponsored
by Science, Technology,
and Business Division here
at the Library of Congress.
Today's topic is One Health.
How many of you know
about One Health?
That's pretty good.
I thought it's a new concept,
but it's actually not new.
So the speaker is going to explain
that it's actually
not a new concept.
We are very, very lucky
to have today's speaker.
She's an expert, not only the
One Health, but she's a director
of the FDA as well as the
advisor still right now
for the George Washington
University's Milken Institute
of Public Health.
And she'll go back, but
this year she wants to share
with you her knowledge
on One Health.
I think it's nice to connect between
public and federal government.
So I'm sure that you know what FDA
is, right, this audience I guess.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's Food and
Drug Administration.
So she'll go back and
serve as a director again.
But it's nice to have this
public and government,
and also maybe company
private sector communication.
That's a very important thing.
And President Obama has been
really pushing this concept.
Today's speaker -- actually,
you have the name here.
I actually knew her name from
her work before I met her.
So Bernadette Dunham.
Dr. Bernadette Dunham has done her
veterinarian degree from Canada
and came here and did a
Ph.D. at Boston University.
And she has served at the
university as well as government.
And she has been bridging
academic and the public sectors.
So she's such a catalyst
in communicating very well,
and very, very friendly person.
So with her approach, she will
explain exactly what One Health
is today.
So without further
ado, please join me
in welcoming our speaker,
Dr. Dunham.
[ Applause ]
>> Bernadette Dunham:
Well, good morning.
Thank you, Dr. Steen, very much.
And thank you for the invitation to
be here at the Library of Congress.
It's really an honor
and I'm thrilled
to see so many in the audience.
So with no further ado,
I am thrilled to be able
to address a number of aspects
of what we now call One Health.
I'm going to cover a number
of examples and wrap it
up at the very end with
an exciting opportunity
to address an annual
One Health Day event.
So the concept of One
Health, it isn't new,
as you just heard from Dr. Steen.
Considering the fact that
over 2,500 years ago,
it was actually Hippocrates who
urged physicians to consider
where their patients
lived, the foods they ate,
the waters they drank,
their lifestyles,
and the seasons of the year.
And then Dr. Virchow, father
of pathology, stated that,
"Between animal and human medicine,
there are no dividing
lines nor should there be."
And then Dr. Schwab, also coined the
term "one medicine" in his textbook
of "Veterinary Medicine
and Human Health" in 1965.
The American Veterinary Medical
Association had a task force in 2008
which really started
to set the framework
for how we can really start
to embrace One Health.
By definition, One Health
is the collaborative effort
of multiple disciplines
working locally, nationally,
and globally to obtain
optimal health for people,
animals, and the environment.
Why do we want to look
at One Health?
Worldwide, about 75 percent of
all emerging infectious diseases
in the past three decades
have originated in animals.
Environmental health can
affect human and animal health
through contamination, pollution,
and poor conditions that often lead
to new infectious agents.
And the world population
is projected to grow
from a current 7.4 billion
to 9 billion in 2050.
We have to be aware of how we
provide adequate healthcare,
food and water for this
growing population.
Our health professions
and related disciplines,
and institutions must work together.
And there's always that
benefit that we experience
from the human/animal bond
to help impact the health
of people and animals.
Three groups that I'm going to
highlight have evolved over time.
One is the One Health
Initiative, it started in 2006.
And it basically is that forte
of recognizing that human health,
animal health, and ecosystem
health are inextricably linked.
And One Health does seek to promote
and prove and defend the health
and well-being of all species
by enhancing cooperation
and collaboration between
physicians, veterinarians,
and other scientific health and
environmental professionals;
and promoting strength in leadership
and management to achieve
these goals.
And they have the umbrella,
as we say, for One Health,
of which here are a
number of examples --
and I'm going to touch
on a few of them today --
that come to mind when
you say, "Well,
what exactly are we talking about?"
And you can have anything
from zoonotic threats
to comparative medicine and
translational medicine to looking
at the environment as
well as our public issues.
Another group that has
evolved, starting in 2009,
is the One Health Commission.
And they really focus with
their charter to educate
and create networks that can
help improve our health outcomes
and well-being for humans,
animals, and plants,
promoting an environmental
resilience
through a collaborative
global One Health approach.
And then most recently in
2011, the One Health platform,
also a global group, has been
formed to try to further the forum
of stakeholders that we
have in really looking
at potential future
outbreaks of zoonoses,
emerging infectious diseases
in animals and people,
and antimicrobial resistance,
and the ecological
factors surrounding them.
Right now, this map
that was generated
by Dr. Monith [assumed spelling],
displays the potential initial
numbers that we're looking
at that are both arthropod-borne,
rodent-borne, as others,
to give us zoonotic infections.
And as you well know, Zika
is certainly rolling off
of everybody's tongues today.
It is the next one to be added
as an arthropod-borne infection.
Put this up because in fact,
we really do now live
in a global village.
So if I look at Zika virus,
it absolutely exemplifies
One Health so well.
It really does need and showcase
how we bring together entomologists,
physicians, veterinarians,
virologists, wildlife biologists,
environmental experts,
universities, governments,
public health organizations,
world health organizations.
Why? Because we have so much to do
to address this very
important issue.
Zika virus infection
is often asymptomatic,
and it can cause mild
illnesses such as just a fever
or a rash, or some joint pain.
But most recently, and what
has been in the newspaper
and caught everybody's
attention, is the fact that now --
and CDC just recently concluded --
Zika virus infection during
pregnancy can cause microcephaly
and other severe fetal
brain defects.
It's possibly also associated
with autoimmune illnesses
like Guillain-Barre Syndrome.
And that's under investigation
as well.
But as of today, there
isn't a commercial vaccine,
nor a specific antiviral agent
to treat Zika virus infection,
so our basic research and vaccine
development needs to continue.
There's also no approved yet
diagnostic test cleared by FDA
to help us detect Zika virus, be it
for blood, urine, or saliva samples.
And the mosquito, Ades genus, the
vector needs to be controlled.
And what are the ways
that we can do that?
Some are looking at removal
of water-containing
sources: insecticide sprays.
And now we have the potential
for genetic engineering
of these mosquitos to
suppress mosquito population.
And society has to take a look at
all of these potential technologies.
And then how do we enhance the
risk communication and education
to help the public
avoid mosquito exposure?
We do need enhanced
surveillance systems collecting,
analyzing the data to assist
in whatever our public
health strategies will be.
We also still have yet to
determine the non-human reservoirs
for Zika virus.
Originally, in the Zika
forest in Africa was
where a monkey had been
looked at that did have access
and was detected to
having positive Zika virus.
But now if you come over to
South America, we don't know
yet for sure what the animal
potential reservoir is,
so this is why we need
further research.
And most importantly,
because of the devastation
of what this virus can do
with newborn infants --
-- those that have microcephaly,
they're going to need potential
medical care for their lives.
And that really means we have
to have infrastructure local,
at national levels, the
financial commitments,
and the government engagement in
policy development that takes place
in order to address this real
challenge that we're facing.
That's just one.
There's a number of the
other mosquito-borne diseases
that I know you're
very familiar with.
If we talk about transmitting
Dengue, Chikungunya, Yellow fever,
Zika viruses from the Aedes
specimen of the mosquitos;
the one thing that we're not aware
of -- you may not be aware of --
is Yellow fever internationally
is actually potentially rising.
And the one thing that is occurring
is we don't always maintain
sufficient of our vaccine
stockpiles.
So if Yellow fever was to take off
in an urban area right about now
in certain parts of the
globe, are we really prepared
to be able to address that?
So those are the questions that
are surfacing on a global level
that we need to be aware
of as we hear and track
and see what diseases are surfacing.
You're also familiar with West Nile
virus, equine encephalitis virus.
We also have Japanese encephalitis
virus being transmitted.
And of course, we have an
[inaudible] transmitting malaria.
And that's a constant
struggle still;
we have not yet overcome malaria.
And then for a lot of folks that
may have some cats and dogs,
we have a mosquito transmission
of dirofilaria immitis,
which causes heartworm.
And a quick aside, we
have a number of products
that you can treat your dog with,
for example, to prevent heartworm.
What's interesting is certain
dogs have a genetic propensity
to carry mutation in a very
important protein that prevents them
from metabolizing correctly
the Ivermectin type
of drugs that we use.
And a quick analogy, if Tommy and
Mary come into a veterinary clinic
with their Collie/Collie-cross
dogs and you want
to treat both those dogs to prevent
heartworm, there's a potential
if you don't screen,
that you might end
up causing the loss of Tommy's dog.
Well, that'll be heartbreaking.
Well now, we can test, and
again, bringing back in the idea
of understanding from genomics,
the fact that we have
personalized medicine for people
and we can have personalized
medicine for animals.
So now with screening, we can
say Tommy's dog cannot receive an
Ivermectin-based product, we'll use
something else and he'll be fine,
and he will be protected
against heartworm.
So medicine is touching
both sides right now.
And of course, emerging
diseases of global health
and agricultural concerns.
You're certainly very aware
that we've had numerous
links over the years.
Certainly, H1N1 has been a crisis.
Back in 2009, we had
a major outbreak.
And we're looking at influenza
from birds, from swine,
and [inaudible] a potential for
them again to jump from species
to species and potentially
then hit humans
and cause some major
important issues.
SARS occurred in 2003, the severe
acute respiratory syndrome,
with people in direct
transmission back and forth.
Ebola. We had another major
outbreak, as you saw in 2014.
We're still addressing
those issues right now.
And again, how do we intervene?
How do we track?
How do we respond quickly enough?
MERS also surfaced, and that
again was your Middle East
respiratory syndrome.
The potential there is
even looking at camels --
is there a source that can
go back as a zoonotic entity?
And I mentioned West
Nile virus earlier.
Certainly when that hit New
York, that was an eye-opener.
Again, we've had Zika, so how
do you handle these vectors
such as mosquitos?
And then we had bovine
spongiform encephalitis,
also called mad cow disease,
outbreak in '86 from Europe.
And then what have we taken for
policy steps to prevent that?
And E.coli O157:H7 has
had devastating results
when it first broke out when we
had the issue with the [inaudible].
We've come a long way, but
we're still facing these issues.
They're with us and
they're challenging.
So how about something local?
Lyme disease.
I think many of us, certainly in
the eastern coast, but it crosses
so many areas, have heard and
maybe have even had Lyme disease.
It's caused by a spirochete,
it's called bacteria,
Borrelia burgdorferi, and
it's transmitted by ticks.
Well, you think about where
we live, we move into so many
of the wooded areas
anymore where deer hang out.
But you know what,
they're also capable then
of transmitting diseases back.
And the ticks that are there,
very quickly will be able to pick
up some of these problems.
And they can touch people, they can
touch dogs, horses -- cats rarely --
cattle and mice are known
to be able to succumb
to Lyme disease just
like you and I can.
Many times, you'll just have
nothing more than flu-like symptoms,
but it also forms both in
early and a chronic form.
And if any of you have had it or if
you've had friends that have had it,
it's very, very, very difficult.
It's constantly being treated.
And people are not happy
when they have Lyme disease.
And it can touch all of
us: children and adults.
With dogs and horses, very similar,
you'll have shifting leg lamenesses,
swollen joints, lethargy,
fever, and [inaudible].
We do fortunately have
a vaccine for dogs.
And people say, "Well,
what about me?
Why don't you have
a vaccine for me?"
And this gets back again
to the research and working
with our companies to say we do
have a need for a specific drug
or a vaccine to be developed.
And I believe there
is still work to try
to get us there, but
we're not there yet.
So your dogs, at least
you can protect them.
And when it comes to
treatment, it's an antibiotic,
and one that's very
typical and used in horses,
dogs, or people: Doxycycline.
Well now, what about
white-nose syndrome in bats?
Why would I want to talk about bats?
Because it's an example of how
we do live in a global world.
And it actually was humans
that brought particularly
this fungus over from Eurasia.
And the bats that we have in North
America had never been exposed
to this before.
And when they did, it
really hit in 2006.
This particular fungus impacts
the bats when they're hibernating,
and literally will
lead to their death.
And we've lost a lot of bats.
So you may say, "Well,
they're just bats.
Why are you bothering with that?"
Because they're very important.
People often don't realize.
They help with pest control.
They night fly, so they'll
take a lot of insects
that can often damage
agricultural crops.
And they're very important
in pollination,
from deserts to rainforests.
The nectar-feeding bats are really
critical in helping pollinate,
and then also for seed dispersion.
There, they can help scatter seeds.
And often times, if you've
had deforestation in a forest,
they can be the ones to
help restore it again.
So knowing we've lost so
many, now going forward,
I still think we're going to see
some significant ecosystem impacts
because of the loss of a very
important pollinator that we have.
And once again, it's bringing
together your scientists, managers,
lawmakers, and the public at large
to try to address this issue,
identify where we're
seeing it, and hopefully see
if the bats can themselves develop
immunity, which often they can
and have in other countries.
But when you first get hit with
something, often it's decimated
to that particular species.
And everybody also has
heard a lot about honeybees.
Bee colonies -- they
continue to fall.
There was a report just
this month both by the --
University of Maryland released the
survey and USDA released a survey.
And here in the United States, the
beekeepers have lost 44 percent
of their colonies just
the last year.
Once again, why are we concerned?
They're bees and you don't
want to get stung, right?
But it's more than that.
Not only do they make the honey that
you like, but they're tremendous
for pollinating so many crops
for the foods that we need.
And I think once again, it's being
aware of this, because we need
to help make a difference
identifying the problem
and come up with solutions.
There's been a variety of
factors that people have looked
at because we haven't pinned
everything down specifically
under what we call
colony collapse disorder
where typically you'll see
a loss of the worker bees.
Very few are dead, but the
hives are basically empty other
than the queen bee and any
of the brood that remains.
But if the worker bees aren't
there to bring back in and continue
to take care of them, then
of course you have nothing.
The other aspect has
been the varroa mite.
This particular mite
has been devastating.
It will continue to
weaken the bee, and again,
fungus and infections can come in
and further decimate the bee colony.
But again, they're so
important for pollination
that we may not see them actually
doing everything they do every day,
but we really see the
impact when all
of a sudden you don't have a crop.
And therefore, when you think
about feeding the world,
it also becomes very important to
sustain and address these issues.
So a lot of research
is ongoing right now.
And then finally, if you take
a look at monarch butterflies,
once again, what do they do for us?
They're a sentinel.
They're one more example of how
things are changing over time.
And when we change the habitat,
when we use insecticides,
many times we can see how the
impact is to a certain species.
And monarch butterflies have one
major source of food: the milkweed.
Well, you think about weeds and
you say, "Let's cut the area.
Let's clear up the fields,"
but you're also taking away one
of their key sources of food.
Also, the extreme weather changes
that we've seen have impacted.
So as we can watch
sentinels, it's important
because it can open our
eyes, we may be able
to intervene sooner
before ramifications come
up on major impact to
us and other animals.
I'm going to shift into the oceans.
We also have a number of marine
environmental sentinels there.
For those of you that love to
go down and see coral reefs
and scuba dive and appreciate the
beauty as you see it all the time,
or even in aquariums, you like
to look at a healthy coral reef.
But as you've heard
and as you're seeing,
many of these reefs are now really
succumbing to oceanic acidification.
And what are we as society doing?
When you think about the impacts we
have from water and how we have --
traveling back and forth
through the oceans with some
of these huge transport vehicles --
sometimes you have horrible
ocean spills of oil.
What is happening as we
continue around our coastal areas
that can further add
to the acidification
and impact these coral reefs?
We're the ones that can
help make a difference.
And together, bringing in the
experts and potentially new research
and scientific technologies,
hopefully intervene
to turn this around.
One piece of news, when
I talk about environment,
is even today in the newspaper,
there was a very good note
that for the Chesapeake Bay
-- in fact, from last year,
they've managed to reduce some of
the land runoff on agriculture,
and in fact, the Bay is
starting to now improve
as they're monitoring
different aspects.
And that's encouraging.
So where there's a
will, there's a way.
We can make a difference.
Healthy green sea turtles.
They've been around for
centuries and they're beautiful.
But you know what,
they're also succumbing
to a number of new issues.
Fibropapillomatosis is a
very devastating disease
in a green sea turtle.
You and I are familiar
with the papilloma virus.
Typically you'll get a
wart, but more importantly,
you can get cervical cancer.
So we have developed vaccines
which I think is very important.
But for the sea turtle, it's because
they're seeing so much stress now
because of the impact on the
environment of the coastal habitat,
when they develop this
particular papilloma virus,
it's herpes five virus,
then you'll see --
as you can see in this
particular picture --
it looks like growths, and they are.
But they end up obstructing
swimming, feeding, buoyancy,
and sometimes they can actually
lead to the death of the animal,
and also blind them if
it grows over their eye.
So once again, it's a sentinel.
And yes, we can individually
intervene and treat some
of these animals, but it's awareness
that as the environment is
being stressed and polluted,
we're impacting so many animals.
And I think it's important that we
take a look at the oceans as well
as what we're doing here
on the land or in the air.
So climate change.
Everybody has a different
view on climate change.
I think there's a lot of
good evidence out there
that we are certainly
seeing some major changes.
Most recently, we've seen
an awful lot of change,
certainly across the United
States, with hurricanes, tornadoes,
in areas that normally we didn't,
or frequency that's increased.
It's absolutely amazing.
Flooding has occurred.
The devastation that
occurs to society
when we deal with major floods.
Yes, we're seeing rising sea
levels because there's evidence
that in fact we have
melting glaciers
and ice fields impacting
polar bears, sentinels.
What's happening?
Who's measuring this?
What's the documentation?
And what, if anything,
can we do about it?
And I think we need to be concerned
because even though sometimes you
getting overwhelmed by thinking,
"What can I possibly do?"
In fact, there's a lot that together
we can do as we become aware
of some of these opportunities.
We've seen increases
of wildfires, too.
And that's devastating not only for
the environment and the wildlife,
but as you've seen,
certainly like California,
it's touching where
people want to live.
And we love the wildlife,
we want to live out there.
These are beautiful,
beautiful -- it's a country --
and yet, there's a lot that
can happen that can turn this
into devastating situation.
And we've seen increased
dryness and drought.
So we as we see this, an example
with drought would be well,
you need to have crops,
you need to have food.
Today, more and more we're seeing
genetically engineered crops,
some of which now can
withstand the drought;
some can withstand certain pests.
So are we ready to accept that?
What's the science behind that?
The modification behind that?
The policies?
And more importantly, how
do we monitor all of this?
So as we are moving -- sometimes
science can move much quicker
than what we're ready to adopt --
but I think it's important that
we sit and look at that science
and the policies that should
be developed to handle this.
And more importantly, to do
it together in a global venue.
Most recently, the White House
just released in April their report
on some of the health risks
that come from climate change.
And they did this because they're
focusing again on how individuals,
communities, organizations,
and governments can proactively
manage some of the health risks
that we see with climate change.
The first one that comes to mind
is absolutely air pollution and all
of the allergens that we see.
So how can we take technologies
and still provide and develop --
clean fuel, for example -- and
not have to have air pollution?
Concentration in cities.
You take a look at some
countries and people have masks
on every day just to walk
around because the
pollution can be so severe.
So people in countries
want to evolve,
you want to have economic
change, but sometimes that brings
with it some very big important
challenges to the health.
So how do we continue
to advance the economy
but also minimize the
negative impact to our health?
Yes, the extremes of heat
and cold come into play,
and how well do we handle that, and
what does that do to your health.
We just highlighted a
minute ago just some
of the intense extreme events
that we've talked about.
How do prepare?
How do you handle some of those?
That's going to be a
challenge for all of us.
And yes, with this, we see increase
of some vectors that can survive
in countries that they
hadn't before.
Or as usual, we travel, animals
travel, and microbes travel.
And as I showed you already,
introduction of new species
that can challenge our health
and animals' health,
and are we ready for it.
Water-related illnesses.
Nothing more than mentioning Flint,
Michigan and lead in the water.
We've seen the reaction of that.
And how do we do and
monitor the infrastructure.
And infrastructure takes dollars,
it's old, it's breaking down.
How can we intervene to make
sure we can keep things safe
so people can have
access to safe water?
Threats to food safety/nutrition.
Even just looking at the pollinators
I mentioned to you can minimize.
Will we still have the
food supply we need?
And all of this really
stresses our mental health.
People have a lot of angst
when they're being stressed,
and that's going to
impact your health.
And I think it's always been true:
there are certain populations
that are going to suffer
a lot more than others,
and there are certain countries
where if they're not well off,
they will be the ones to suffer
the most than those of us
that are very fortunate and
can possibly handle this.
Another good report --
this came out this year --
preventing disease through
healthy environments.
This is the World Health
Organization
that just released this.
And again, taking a look
at, in this global world,
how much can we potentially turn
around through the environment,
some of the risk factors
that we have evolved,
that we have actually been
part and parcel of causing.
And the good news is that even
though 23 percent of global debts
and 26 percent among children
under five, they're related
to modifiable environmental factors.
So if we can reduce air
pollution, if we can assure access
to safe water, if we can have
the basic sanitation that, again,
we often take for granted
but in other countries they don't
have that, and access to clean fuel.
The pictures here and in the report
can really highlight how we can make
a difference, but it's
at a cost, and it's going
to take society working together.
It's going to take us helping
and lowering the pillars
so that internationally, we
can learn from each other,
we can assist, and we can get to a
sustainable level and minimize some
of those factors and
get the benefits
that we want from today's
technology.
Switching gears.
Translational biology.
Now, very close to my heart, how
do we advance One Health here?
Well, many of you may have pets.
Many of you may have had
friends, or yourself,
who might have been
touched by cancer,
and many of your pets may also
have been touched by cancer.
The Institute of Medicine,
last year,
held a workshop entitled The
Role of Clinical Studies for Pets
with Naturally Occurring Tumors
in Translational Cancer Research.
The National Cancer Institute has
what we call comparative oncology
trials consortium.
And this has been set up solely for
the infrastructure to take a look at
and investigate clinical
trials for our pets
that have the naturally
occurring tumors.
And how learning from them --
and I'm going to show you in
a minute some similarities
that can easily be translated to and
help in fact address human cancers.
And there's a benefit because
it's a win on both sides
when we can have interventions
through drugs,
surgery for pets as
well as for people.
And right now we have
over 20 academic comparative
oncology centers.
So maybe you've had a Scottie dog.
Well, in this day and
age of genomics
and understanding the sequencing of
the genome, we learned an awful lot.
Well, Scottish Terriers
are 19 times more likely
to develop bladder cancer
[inaudible] the transitional cell,
carcinoma, it's a BRAF
gene mutation.
And in people with the same
tumor, it's a BRAF gene mutation.
And at the meeting, it
was just so thrilling
to see your board-certified
human oncologists,
your board-certified veterinary
oncologists looking and talking
to each other and saying, "Really?
I had no idea."
"Fabulous, because now we
can talk and work together."
At the same time, Dr. Rod
Page, who I have here,
he's with the Flint Cancer
Center at Colorado State.
He was one of the key folks to
work and encourage the Institute
of Medicine to put this workshop on.
And he's also been fabulous in
highlighting where we can learn
from our pets that have
spontaneous tumors.
Take a look at osteosarcomas.
Devastating on both cases.
And many times limbs are amputated
to try to treat an osteosarcoma.
Once again, at this particular
study, when you take a look
at the clinical trials and the
tissues from dogs or from people,
you'll find again that gnomically,
they're very, very similar.
So the venue there would be could
we take a look and develop a drug?
And you could be using this
literally for your dog to be able
to hopefully extend their life
as well as their quality of life,
and then glean from that
information that can move forward
to hopefully attain
and get successful drug
approval on the human side.
So this is a very exciting
opportunity.
Our pets don't live as
long as us, so therefore,
you can have information gathered
in a much shorter time period.
So there's a win there.
And then curiosity.
Are you aware of the fact that
elephants rarely develop cancer?
Well, actually, taking a look
at potentially some
evolutionary-based medicine,
a number of researchers
have looked at this.
And one thing that was very curious,
they found that elephants have
about 20 copies of
what we call TP53.
This encodes for a protein, p53,
that's a very crucial
tumor suppressor gene.
Well, they have 20 copies.
But guess what?
You and I only have one.
Is that possibly why?
It's most interesting to see that.
So once again, understanding
different scenarios.
And as genomics opens up the door
more and more, we can take a look
at what's behind some of the
tumors that we're looking at
and how cancer is evolving, and how
can we intervene and hopefully come
up with better ways of
potentially addressing cancer,
which touches so many of our lives.
That just showcases a number of
the trial consortiums that we have.
Another example, cranial
facial reconstruction
through regenerative technology
can benefit animals and people.
So for the dog side.
Often, dogs will get malignant
and sometimes even benign tumors
of the mandible, and
they'll undergo surgery.
This little diagram on the
bottom shows a dog's skull.
And if you can look
there, you'll see it looks
like just a regular
plate, but there's a mark
that shows you the section of the
jaw that's trying to say, fuse.
So if it had just been a clean
break of a bone, you could do that.
You plate -when your bone is broken,
you can just plate
it and it'll heal.
Sometimes, whole sections
of the jaw are removed.
And when that happens, they've
often gone and used bone grafts
in the past, but the
results really weren't ideal.
Now you fast forward with today's
technology and understanding
of science, and in
fact, on the human side,
FDA has approved two spinal
fusion products for use in people,
and it consists of what we now call
recombinant human bone morphogenetic
proteins, for short, RHBMPs.
What they really are, they're
special growth factors,
and they can absolutely help induce
formation of bone and cartilage.
So now, we can treat
people and dogs similarly.
And you'll be able to take, in this
case, if there had been a tumor
and you took it out, the two
pictures on the bottom show
if you'd just use a collagen
matrix, you can see it's still kind
of bluey/purple in the middle.
It has really got all of the
bone forming very nicely.
But if you do the collagen and
you then also add the RHBMPs,
you can see it looks like
bone all the way through.
Much quicker, you get a
really good reconstruction,
and the benefits are fantastic.
So again, One Health advances both.
I can't resist.
We see this, and we often
times are guilty of it.
I for one do have a
slightly overweight pussycat.
It's too easy, with our treats, to
have our little pets become obese.
And we're just about as bad
sometimes if we're not careful.
But the issue then is the health.
And the health that
really comes from obesity
or being overweight
really is type 2 diabetes,
because that's one we can
change through exercise,
through eating healthy, we
can improve and minimize that.
But it also can stress
us across the board
from cardio respiratory disease,
you can have hip problems
and knee problems, and of course
cancer is a potential as well.
So as you can see from the diagram,
sometimes nothing more than just get
up and take your dog for a walk,
go for a walk yourself, exercise.
And even though it's so nice to stop
by and get these fast food sometimes
that are processed, trying to focus
on healthy dieting is
something we can all embrace.
And that'll be good
because that'll help us all.
So after talking about One
Health, how are we starting
to bridge this back into
academic curriculums?
And I'm very, very thrilled that
just this past year, the Association
of American Veterinary Medical
Colleges with the Association
of Preventive Teaching and Research
under the Healthy People Curriculum
Task Force has developed 15 case
studies to showcase literally
how One Health can be brought
into the academic situation.
They're available online.
They're fabulous case studies
for you to take a look at.
But the whole goal there is to
really help our students be able
to get the knowledge and skills
needed to really address potentials
for transmission of human and
animal disease, how to prevent it,
how to address the health
issues once they've surfaced,
and what policies need to happen.
And then under that One Health
principle, recognizing who needs
to be invited to the table so we can
drop the pillars and work together.
And that's really the
biggest challenge
in how One Health can
hopefully minimize that.
So the 15 case studies,
I've listed them there.
Do take advantage of taking a look.
They're very enlightening
and interesting,
and anybody can read them and
appreciate some of these examples.
They really are good.
And the wrapping up, we always
thought, when we had discovery
of penicillin, that we had the magic
bullet and we were not going to have
to deal with any kind of infections
again; but that's not true.
Because even Sir Alexander
Fleming --
discovery of penicillin also
receiving the Nobel Prize,
cautioned resistance is a natural
counterpart to antibiotics.
Welcome to the world of microbes.
And this now, once again, is
an international global issue.
Over the past decade, I think
we've seen some major concerns.
Nothing could be more heartbreaking
than to have an infection
and to have the physician tell
you, "I'm so sorry, I have nothing
to treat you or your family with."
And even more heartbreaking to
see that member of the family die.
So this is not to be taken
lightly; it's very serious.
And we all have to be involved.
Are we capable of developing
some new antibiotics?
For the longest time
after this development,
we didn't think we needed them.
They focused on virology
and vaccines.
Now come fast forward, we
don't have in the armamentarium
of drugs a lot of new antibiotics.
So as we understand the genome
of the microbe, are there ways
that we can come up with new
development of procedures
to treat these particular microbes?
This brings us all together:
public health, agriculture,
research, national security.
I mentioned it earlier,
it's so true,
international travel has
really opened up the capability
of having these microbes
and the resistance
that they carry come over here.
You could have an injury
when you're walking in India
and get an infection, and come
back home here and all of a sudden,
boom, you have an infection.
And guess what?
It's a microbe and we don't have
that particular to treat it with.
That's devastating, and
that has actually happened.
So we do need to be very cautious
and we all have to be stewards --
when I say stewards -- of
how we use these products,
be it for our own health,
taking care of our kids,
taking care of our animals.
And more importantly, major
changes that I'm very proud
of at FDA is we really [inaudible]
in the case of how historically,
some very important
antimicrobials were being used
in production agriculture.
Way back when, some of our food
animals received these products
and they seemed to do very well.
They grew, they stayed
healthy -- well, that's nice.
But that definition is
not good enough today.
You need to know why are
you using an antibiotic,
what species is it being used
in, what dose range, how long,
and what pathogen are you treating.
And it really needs to be
properly handled through physicians
for people and for
veterinarians for animals.
And so now we have made those
changes and we're seeing all
of that happen with a proper label.
And by January 2017 on
the food animal side,
any of these medically
important antibiotics will
in fact have proper labels.
And the idea of thinking they could
have been used for growth promotion,
feed efficiency will
not happen anymore.
So again, there needs
to be very cautious use
of these very important products.
Along those lines, we did have
an executive order to try to come
up with a game plan of combatting
antibiotic-resistant bacteria.
And it pleased me again to see
that in fact number two is
strengthen the national One Health
surveillance effort
to combat resistance.
Again, we do need to study this,
we need to be surveilling this,
and we need to be able to
accelerate the research
to give us the tools that we need.
Potentially even vaccines
can help as well here.
But it's also going to improve
international collaboration
and sharing of information
that we see.
Center picture says it all.
No words are needed.
When we have the benefits of
the human/animal interactions,
via from service dogs to our
service animals, to the love
and companionship that
our animals give us.
They really don't ask for very
much, but they give so much.
Really, really does help all
of us with our mental health,
and I think so important,
companionship all the way through.
They are jewels, and
therefore, we want to make sure
that we take care of them.
But also, we need to be aware
of when they can be the ones
to transmit some potential
harmful diseases to us.
So wrapping up, politics
has to get involved.
If we're going to have these pillars
drop down, we need people to help
at the level of the government.
Most recently, there was
the One Health Act of 2016
that was introduced by Congress.
And if this happens, it's
sole focus is to do just that.
So how do we get federal agencies to
work together to try to address some
of these infectious diseases?
How do we prevent them?
Could we get grants so that
instead of just a silo of I'm going
to get a grant from this one agency,
and I'm going to go over here
for a separate grant for a
different agency, but yet,
we want to work together.
We need to have the granting
agencies be able to acknowledge
and say it's OK for different
backgrounds to apply for a grant
and work together,
and most importantly,
to publish together and
to make that easier.
When I think about where do I go for
a competitive grant for a disease
in a cat or a dog,
pretty hard to find that.
ONH is really going to
focus on the human side.
USDA is really going to focus
on more so the food/animal side.
So there's areas.
And EPA will be doing
your environmental side.
But when something crosses and
it's a health issue for both sides,
then hopefully we can
encourage the granting agencies
and Congress to open up the doors.
And then of course,
internationally, how do you deal
with the World Bank/World
Health organization?
Because we do need to take a look
at sharing data, working together,
and learning from each other.
So this morning I took
advantage in a very short moment
to give you examples of so
many opportunities that come
under that wonderful
umbrella of One Health.
And these have highlighted
through the talk examples.
There's many more that
I'm sure each one
of you could add do an
entire presentation on.
But I think it's heightening
that awareness,
and bringing this together
is really the goal.
And most recently, to let
you know, there is going
to be an international symposium
on One Health in Mongolia in June.
There is going to be a
second global conference
on One Health in Japan in November.
And then in December,
Melbourne is going
to host the convention
on One Health EcoHealth.
So I'm really pleased to
see this being embraced
in so many broad brushstrokes.
And finally, there
is a desire to see
that we can maybe have even
annually a One Health Day.
So the very first one we've
chosen is November 4th,
and it's an international
campaign which has been coordinated
by the three groups I highlighted
at the start of the talk --
the One Health Commission,
One Health Initiative,
and One Health Platform
Foundation --
to really bring attention around the
world for how these interactions are
so crucial, and that we
benefit by working together.
And this campaign is going
to highlight literally
around the world a number
of projects ongoing,
they can be small,
they can be large.
But it's the idea to show
with inspiration so many ways
that we can work together.
And by working together,
I truthfully believe
that we can make a difference and
we can attain health for people,
animals, and for our environment.
And I thank you so very much for the
opportunity to speak with you today.
[ Applause ]
>> Tomoko Steen: [Inaudible]
ask questions
and the speaker is
going to [inaudible].
>> I wondered what you thought of
the Olympics in Brazil and what --
but I know that the low end has
got our people in short shorts,
where the Japanese have
the parachute long clothes.
Do you think it's safe for
people to -- and the Olympics.
>> Bernadette Dunham: So the
question what do we think
about attending the Olympics to be
held this year in Brazil knowing
that Zika virus is a concern.
And the clothing that
various members
of the Olympic teams coming
internationally should
or should not wear.
This is definitely a
major issue of concern.
And I think aspects of how one can
protect oneself courtesy of yes,
you know, various insecticide
sprays.
Clothing certainly is true.
So if I was going to have
shorts, I'd definitely want
to make sure I had some
repellant on my skin, for example.
I think is Brazil is doing a
tremendous job on communicating
to enhance awareness
of what people can do.
They're really, really
focusing, I think right now,
heavily on both the
insecticide spray,
they actually have some potentials
for reducing the population
of mosquitos.
But it's still something that
you have to take responsibility
for your own health
and be very cautious.
And I do think there's
a number of entities
that allows us to ensure that.
So each person should be
aware and then make a decision
as to how they want to go forward.
And I think all of the
Olympic teams in the countries
around the world are
paying attention to this
to try to minimize the problem.
And by far, if we did have
the capability, as I said,
for diagnostics to
be able to fine tune,
it would help a tremendous amount
to reassure someone, you know,
having been exposed or not.
So in the meantime, Zika has
been around for a little while,
but most recently it's been the
major, major scare for the potential
for this transmission of the
microcephaly in pregnant women.
And many times, as I mentioned,
if we did we get exposed,
you will develop some
antibodies towards it,
so you'll probably be fine.
But it's the pregnancy that
becomes the biggest issue of all.
And then as you know, the
potential sexual transmission
of this becomes an issue.
So education, education,
education is needed right now,
and then having people make
informed and safe decisions.
Does that help?
>> Great. Thanks.
>> Bernadette Dunham:
You're welcome.
Yes, sir.
>> So there's been a lot of emphasis
in recent years on using viruses
to treat certain illnesses like
[inaudible] with brain cancer.
So can you talk a little bit about a
One Health perspective on the future
of that type of treatment?
Can using a virus to treat a disease
cross species in a way that some
of these other things
can [inaudible]?
>> Bernadette Dunham:
So the question is,
moving back into the
medical side, can we use some
of the various viruses that we
looked at and can they be used
to prevent and treat
certain diseases.
And I think that is one area
that is becoming very exciting
because we are using
many times a virus vector
to transfer in a treatment modality.
We have to be very careful
that some of the viruses
that we use are not
going to cause illness.
And that perfection of
the dose needs to be
and is being looked at right now.
So it's a very good
tool, but coordination
and still the research
is exciting opportunities
which I think the future
is going to unfold more
and more as we go forward.
So yes, it's a good question
and it's definitely being looked
at with potentials that
could be very beneficial.
Yes, sir.
>> How do you relate One Health
to [inaudible] you have lots
of people [inaudible] nowadays,
like, basically refugees and just
for the climate reasons, and
this has affected disease
around the world?
Does this tie in to this also?
>> Bernadette Dunham: So the
question is how do we look
at the population of people in
different countries and refugees --
>> Population [inaudible].
>> Bernadette Dunham: And then
where they're concentrated,
and we're looking at
potentials for climate change,
how does that overall fall
under the One Health umbrella?
>> More or less having basically
people coming from one country
to another without being
screened for diseases.
>> Bernadette Dunham: OK.
Having people travel from one
country to another without being --
>> Particularly refugees.
>> Bernadette Dunham:
Without being screened.
And that is definitely the
challenge that we're facing.
When I mentioned the concern
even with Yellow virus and where
that could go, the
scenario is just that --
what's the screening
capability that we have?
People do travel back and forth.
You may not even get sick but be
exposed, and then go back home
to your country and be able
to be potentially transmitting
this infection.
I think more importantly, it's
just that heightened awareness
of what are the various
diseases that are
in certain countries
that we're aware of.
And through that type of
surveillance, be able to caution
if someone is then
traveling to another country
where that disease is not known,
then are setting them up to have
that new disease nestle in
and challenge our health
or potential health of animals.
This is the whole idea
behind One Health
which is surveillance is a major,
major important part of that,
and are we aware of what is
happening in various countries.
How do we assimilate
that information?
The more that we can, the more that
we can advise or be on the lookout
when someone is traveling that
we can hopefully follow them.
People often times may not want
to say, "Well, I have been exposed
to said disease, therefore
I can't travel.
Many times, they may stay silent,
and that can do a lot of harm.
So it's turning it
around to be supportive
and to showcase how together
we need to protect your health
and the health of other people.
It's really back to can we
afford infrastructure wise
for these diagnostic tests if
that's what it's going to be.
So the surveillance is one
that information that we have,
if we can find ways of sharing
that and minimizing the cost,
that's another one that will
open up the doors for being aware
and hopefully taking
advantage of One Health.
Does that help?
>> Then to follow up,
what sort of related --
where you have say Dengue in the
low lying areas of the country,
but the internal parts [inaudible]
the same set of diseases.
Are things changes whereas
there's more interactions
so the highlands will
get the lowland diseases
and vice versa [inaudible]?
>> Bernadette Dunham: So
the question is with Dengue,
which you see typically around your
coastal areas if you come inland
or higher elevations, would you
therefore see the transmission.
Part of that goes into
the vector itself
in the transmission capabilities.
So right now, the mosquito is very
happy all on the coastal areas,
but how far north can
it go or survive?
That would be an issue
to track and see just
where that mosquito is
basically surviving.
But then if you have been
exposed to Dengue and you travel
into the Colorado Mountains,
your potential is
for you and probably you alone.
Then whether or not --
-- another mosquito is capable of
picking that up and then surviving
and transmitting it in Colorado,
this is where you need the
surveillance and understanding
of the various vectors
such as mosquitos
and what they will
or will not transmit.
They don't always transmit
each one of these diseases;
that needs to be looked into.
Same with the ticks.
Different ticks will transmit
certain diseases or not.
But this again is opening up
everybody's eyes to an awareness
that we probably didn't have
before, and with that awareness,
what are potential new tools that
we need to have to be able to track
and see what's happening.
Or does there need to be a
specific host that can sustain
that particular disease so that
then a vector can come along
and continue to transmit it.
Aedes is in Asia, but in fact,
we haven't had Yellow fever
breakout in a major way.
So potential is there.
And you say, "Well, why hasn't it?"
And I think it's very
important that we look at areas
where Aedes is surviving, yet
you don't have specific diseases.
And yet it's a great transmitter
of that, and you have to say why.
So this is I think that
awareness of surveillance,
and these questions
need to be asked,
and then bring our researchers
and our entomologists together
to understand more about this.
Because if we can learn from
certain locations or environments,
maybe we can modify
those and have them
as interventions in other countries.
Thank you.
Yes, ma'am.
>> What impact can One Health have
on bioterrorism and agroterrorism,
is it just raising
awareness of the issue
or bringing together
governments to make sure
that they don't utilize those
tactics; what does One Health do?
>> Bernadette Dunham: So the
question is One Health and how
that would handle bioterrorism
across the board.
So many of the biological
entities that are used
in bioterrorism are those exactly,
the zoonotic entities
that we talked about.
Anthrax was used here
up on the Hill.
The potential for some
of these viruses is huge.
It's that awareness
again of why nations need
to understand the devastation
that would occur
through a biological agent
that if that transmission,
especially being transmitted from
people to people for example,
is huge, then in this global world,
it doesn't take much
to have that spread.
And that annihilation is
horrific to even think about it.
So it think it's more
important, and this is why as even
with the nuclear weapon discussion,
the devastation is so huge,
everybody needs to do everything
they can to prevent that.
So the education of what
these biological viruses
and agents can do is one that
we would hope would be forefront
and the government agencies to
say we're not going to go there.
A lot of good can come from so
much of the research that we have,
and the understanding of so many
of these important entities.
But you're right.
You flip the coin and they can
suddenly become the most horrific
agents that we've ever seen if
we don't have a way to intervene.
For some of these agents, we
may or may not have a treatment
or a vaccine, and how
long does it take
to develop those interventions,
is it a challenge?
And then how do you stockpile
so that you're prepared?
So I agree with you.
I would hope that our nations
internationally can work together
and avoid going there, but it's only
through that heightened awareness.
And that gets back again to then how
do you do the surveillance to track
and see what's happening, and
only through us acknowledging
that we do live together
in this world.
So what's going to happen just
across the ocean can
still impact us.
That mindset, I think is
starting to change more and more.
That's a good question.
Thank you.
Yes, ma'am.
>> Does FDA have any
cooperative programs
where they assist developing
countries with developing processes
for drug approvals or for
diagnostic test approvals?
I mean, there are a lot of neglected
[inaudible] diseases out there
that we don't have here, therefore,
there's no incentive for a lot
of [inaudible] activity here.
But certainly FDA has expertise
that could be shared by helping
out countries that do
have these problems.
>> Bernadette Dunham: The question
is does FDA have programs whereby
the staff that has
this knowledgebase
of the drug approval process,
can they assist other countries
where in fact they do have diseases
that we might not have here,
and can they assist
in developing programs
for drug approval in
the other countries.
And there's a number
of groups where we look
at international harmonization
literally for human drugs
and animal drugs on how
countries can share information
and work together and have the
pharmaceutical companies literally
be able to go through
the process of bringing
to fruition approved products
in different countries,
taking advantage of
that knowledgebase.
Many times, we have workshops and
sessions to go to other countries
to showcase examples of how they can
develop their own regulatory program
for drug approval.
And the companies themselves
often participate
to enhance that awareness.
Wherever we can, I think the
part that's so critical --
and we see this even with HIV --
so we have potential products
that can be used to treat people,
but then how do we make those
available and affordable
when you're looking
across the world?
And that's going to bring
the countries together
to address these issues as well.
So there is that capability.
And a number of governments
will come here and visit with us
and learn how do you do A, B, C, D,
E. And if we can show them different
venues at different levels --
so what exactly do you need?
It may not be the same as a
different country over here.
You may want the full
monty; you may not.
And we can help, and
other countries can help
that have full regulatory programs
onboard to work with countries
that are coming forward
and developing their own.
Thank you.
>> Tomoko Steen: Please join me
to thank again for Dr. Dunham.
>> Bernadette Dunham:
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.